what is the deadliest drug in America
yeah it's the one that is legal in all
50 states of course it is alcohol a
really interesting new study just came
out we've got the link to the study
right down below because it is really
expansive and we've only got a couple
minutes here on the YouTube so you can
check that out if you want more info all
right so let's give you some more info
on the study the authors of the study
assessed the comparative risk of death
that accompanies consuming everything
from weed to meth and found that weed is
even safer than they previously believed
researchers drew these conclusions based
on the margin of exposure which measures
the likelihood of an average user
accidentally ingesting a toxic dose the
lower the ratio the smaller the margin
for error and the easier it is to
consume a harmful dose okay now we've
got a graph for you and I'll lay out
what's going on here as you can see in
the chart weeds average margin for error
the red bar is much higher than that of
other drugs meaning the likelihood of
consuming a harmful dose is lower you
pretty much can't do it with weed the
margin for error for alcohol meanwhile
is very low reflecting a much higher
risk of harmful consult consumption
we've got a little more info for you
take a look at this graph whoa the
government Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention study of drug mortality
rates which tallies confirm cause the
death puts a fine point on how obviously
backwards these drug laws have become
and here's where you can see that very
very clearly what are people dying of
tons and tons of people dying from
tobacco tons of people dying from
alcohol look at that the number on the
right Anna what do you make of that zero
on the marijuana I'm glad that more
studies are coming out proving that
there is no way that you're gonna die
from smoking marijuana you're not gonna
overdose from smoking marijuana but at
the same time I do worry a little bit
about some of the way that these stories
are covered because I think it is
irresponsible to say that marijuana is
completely harmless you're not gonna die
it's not gonna ruin your life right but
there are people that become dependent
and it does have some negative impacts
on their lives on their productivity and
so I want to see more of those studies
as well but I think that this is
something that we all pretty much
already knew right and I'm glad that
there's more scientific evidence to kind
of prove the naysayers wrong it's
dick Ulis there are some people in the
country thousands in fact that are
serving life sentences for simple
possession of marijuana we need to
change our laws regarding that just
based on evidence like this right so I
give I give Obama a lot of [ __ ] but he
has done actually pretty decent job on
marijuana laws pretty much the feds
actually still can come in and close
dispensaries here even in California
where it's medicinal illegal marijuana
are ER you don't smoke marijuana right
I've only had pot once and it was on
accident and it was a lot so it was
inedible okay I was at somebody who was
a host on this networks party and there
were these brownies and I thought they
were regular brownie so I had four oh my
god it got weird after that so I mean
you must have been like tripping balls
hey no no that's not that II too much oh
my god honey yeah I I remember taking an
edible and I thought I literally thought
I was gonna die but they keep reminding
myself it's just marijuana is just
marijuana I just drove right no weird I
didn't so even that I think is the point
and even you're part with edibles for
yourself that you did it right and did
you want marijuana the next no I'm done
like I don't mean isn't that rude why
it's not that dangerous
I will Ana's right it's not completely
harmless like I did feel like I
shouldn't drive after this yeah but you
know I didn't I don't think I was in
danger of dying I don't feel like I'm in
danger of being addicted right of but
changing my life in that way yeah do you
think that the weed things already done
like to me it's happening as quickly as
gay marriage once gay marriage really
became an issue say like four or five
years ago I know it took a long time to
get to that point but once it really
became part of the national discussion
it's happened pretty quick I mean
freaking Alabama has it right Texas
there's some legal stuff going on down
there
I feel like weed is just gonna follow
that path absolutely I mean there's
already a lot of momentum for legalizing
marijuana for recreational use right now
there are ten states that are
considering it for recreational use that
means that you're not using it because
you have cataracts you're using it
because you want to get the munchies and
sit on the couch and watch TV and the
government acknowledges that they're
cool with it which is great um but I
mean think about this Washington
Colorado now alas Alaska DC Oregon these
are all places in the US where you can
perch
just and consume marijuana for
recreational use and I think that's a
good sign yeah does do the weed people
need lobbyists like to me it seems like
more I think they're getting some
lobbyists now and we've already seen
that in Colorado the tax revenue is
great so it's to me and this is
something that Republicans should be for
because if they really are for small
government you wouldn't care what
someone smokes in their bedroom right
and you'd be finding another way to get
taxes I think a lot of this is just
misinformation like the pervasive
thoughts that oh it's scary it's bad
stay away from it it's awful you know
but it I think this is all based on a
very old propaganda campaign so you know
maybe we do need some lobbyists for this
cause yeah so then actually should we be
are we talking about this in Reverse
should we really be talking about how
bad booze is like I'm not saying we'd be
a little going for prohibition again but
we don't really talk about that at all
those debts are through the roof drunk
driving etcetera etcetera yeah I think
that we have a problem with tobacco
deaths and alcohol deaths both
substances are completely legal in the
country of course they're regulated to
some degree but you know I think that
there should be more education campaigns
out there that help those who are
addicted to both of those substances cuz
that's the big issue that's the real
problem here all right there you go I
would be for education not regulation
what do you think let us know in the
comments right down below